you didn't see this guy he was a pro and
he brought quite a lot of firepower for
such an easy target yeah he was so extra
right I mean I could take that girl out
with like a fly swatter and he rocks up
in this urban assault vehicle so we're
thinking what he was maybe she was being
watched but what if we are and by who
hey I'm kind of getting this you know
you guys are like lady spies and I just
need you to explain who this guy is and
why was he shooting at you
oh you he was shooting at you me the
shooters are ghosts your file says that
you are a systems engineer on the
Callisto project uh you know about
Callisto we know about a lot of things
that you graduated top of your class at
MIT that you take Krav Maga on Sundays
you ride your bike to work you think
yellow is one of your colors when in
fact it's no one's that you could be
dating a lot more if you played up those
cheekbones and your online profile
pictures what we don't know is why
someone once you did I felt like it was
a great time to reinvigorate Charlie's
Angels who always been about the
sisterhood I also think it's really fun
to fight bad guys with your friends
oh just a decoy stir whisk she sees me
she made me feel so able like the exact
reason she's making this movie the way
that we as women can only build each
other up because we know each other
through and through
Liz wanted these women to feel authentic
because together we are better I did
this movie because the lizbo spotted
project Elizabeth Banks is a powerhouse
she wrote produced directed and starred
in the movie and that's never happened
before in the Charlie's Angels franchise
my name is puzzly I'm gonna kick your
ass whisked up this world and just
expanded it we're louder we are stronger
in numbers the best part isn't peeking
down international criminals it's this
it's the you guys taking down criminals
it's also fun seeing women being the
heroes on screen it's important
I wanted to make something that felt
important to limiting girls the
celebration of what women can accomplish
when they work together take her to the
closet
get her up I just get to take whatever I
want
Laura is that an actual room so in the
first pocket there's another closet
[Music]
[Music]